la citadelle du Kremlin dans toute sa
grandeur en pleine nuit à quelques jours
des célébrations du 9 mai un objet
explose dans la noirceur provoquant une
colonne de fumée au-dessus du dôme du
Sénat la vidéo a été diffusée en boucle
tel quel par les médias des tarus comme
seul et unique preuve de ce que le
kremelait considère aujourd'hui comme
une attaque de drones menée par
l'Ukraine dans le but d'éliminer le
président Vladimir Poutine
à cette question le président de
l'Ukraine en visite enfinlande Annie
tout implication
comme tant d'autres capitales d'autres
sérieusement de la version russe des
événements
pris pour cible en pleine nuit ne
peuvent pas être indépendamment vérifiés
selon les services secrets russes deux
drones ont été abattus par des systèmes
de défense radar il s'agirait d'une
attaque terroriste menée par
l'ukrainer qu'ils ont été lancés depuis
la périphérie de Moscou de cette analyse
militaire à la télévision des tas mais
comment et par qui dans un communiqué le
Kremlin donne peu de détail mais écrit
que la Russie se réserve le droit de
prendre des mesures de représailles ou
et quand elle le jugera opportun
Kiev les sirènes ont retenti toute la
journée au cas où la Russie se manifeste
sur place le porte-parole du président
Hélène ski indique le Kremlin cherche
une provocation pour justifier une
nouvelle escalade
ce n'est pas la première fois que la
Russie accuse comme ça l'Ukraine d'avoir
commandé des attaques transfrontalières
mais c'est à soupe présumé contre le
Kremlin l'un des édifices les mieux
gardés du monde seraient dans une classe
à part
surtout à quelques jours du grand défilé
du 9 mai qui commémore en Russie la fin
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale un
événement auquel Poutine participe sans
faute en personne et en temps réel
chaque année sur la place rouge mais il
est hors de question de la nuit les
préparatifs se poursuivent avec des
mesures de sécurité renforcées ce défilé
non seulement sacré Vladimir Poutine en
a besoin plus que jamais pour rallier
les Russes ici Tamara Alteresco
Radio-Canada Montréal
avec nous bonsoir Tamara bonsoir est-ce
que d'abord les accusations du Kremlin
qui accuse keV d'avoir tenté
d'assassiner Poutine que c'est crédible
d'abord Poutine n'était pas là il est
rarement au Kremlin je pense qu'il faut
le mentionner puis il y a peu de chance
qu'un drone réussit sa pénétrer le
bunker dans lequel il se trouve quand il
est au Kremlin ceci dit oui c'est
crédible dans la mesure où n'importe qui
vous et moi peuvent manipuler un drone
de nos jours et ce qui est difficile à
confirmer aujourd'hui c'est d'où venait
ses drones la seule image qu'on a c'est
l'unique source c'est celle du Kremlin
celle qui joue en boucle depuis toute la
journée à la télévision russe et presque
24 heures plus tard personne peut plus
que l'Ukraine que Washington peut
authentifier vérifier cette vidéo donc
faut se fier au fait du Kremlin donc
est-ce que c'est crédible ou pas pour le
moment on n'a pas sur quoi se reposer
pour pour analyser l'information mais
ces crédible dans le sens où oui ça
serait pas la première fois que Moscou
accuse l'Ukraine de perpétrer des
attaques
transfrontalières donc au-delà de son
territoire et là je parle pas de la
Crimée que l'Ukraine considère bien
évidemment la sienne mais des attaques
sur des trains à brianz par exemple ce
que l'Ukraine ni catégoriement et ça
pourrait aussi justifier des riposte de
Moscou plus agressive à voir ou
provoquer l'annulation du 9 mai bon le 9
mai qui arrive grande fête patriotique
ça crée souvent dit à l'émission C'est
il y a pas de mots pour décrire de la
victoire bolchevique etc c'est la fête
de la victoire de l'armée russe contre
l'Allemagne nazie en plus dans les
circonstances c'est important alors
comment il se comment Poutine se porte à
l'approche de cette fête importante en
état de faiblesse ou de force moi de
faiblesse sur le terrain ils sont pas
capables de gagner
un analyste militaire très crédible en
Russie qui pour la première fois
aujourd'hui me dit ne me cite pas parce
que j'ai peur des représailles qui me
disaient c'est la panique en Russie à la
veille du 9 mai c'est le seul événement
de l'année où on sait où est Poutine à
quel heure et en temps réel à l'air
libre comme on dit au lieu d'être un
moving target comme on dit en anglais
comme il est maintenant dans des traits
blindés ou dans des avions presque plus
d'ailleurs là on sait qui peut pas
utiliser de doublure il peut pas ne pas
être là il y a des chefs d'État il y a
des gens pour vérifier donc c'est un
événement qui évidemment le met à risque
est-ce que c'était pas une tentative
d'intimidité le Kremlin à la veille de
ce c'est possible la réponse on l'a pas
aujourd'hui mais oui à la veille de
célébrations qu'on ne veut pas annuler
qu'on a annulé dans certaines villes de
Russie mais pas à Moscou on est stressé
à Moscou et à quelques jours en quelques
secondes peut-être de cette fameuse
contre-offensive ukrainienne qu'on
atteint qu'on dit qu'elle se prépare
qu'on attend vers le sud probablement
vers la région de reverson qui
veut le direci qui était avec les
nouveaux membres de l'OTAN aujourd'hui
en Finlande pour demander encore des des
avions et du soutien militaire et le
confirmer que oui cette contre-offensive
sera grande et qu'elle est en
préparation ça me remercie beaucoup au
revoir au revoir